brady in 2002
won his first of the uh uh seven super
bowls george bush was president
justin timberlake was still the member
of nsync and a chief's quarterback
patrick mahomes was six years old
companies that advertised during tom
brady's first super bowl aol
so that's why i went with our guy first
aol then blockbuster
think about blockbuster did a super bowl
commercial in 2002.
radio shack circuit city
comp usa sears hot jobs
yahoo voice stream wireless and gateway
computers
is that not crazy how many of those
companies are still relevant well first
of all
relevant or around there's a big
difference both okay you all are still
around radio shack is somewhat still
around
blockbusters uh sears is around you got
uh
yahoo is around gateway yes really four
of them
so voice streams wireless i looked it up
they're actually
what we know is t-mobile today okay uh
they were
it's they were spun off and they were
acquired and then they were purchased
um gateway computers and uh
comp usa were all bought by were both
bought by the same company which is a
computer component company
uh you have radio shack was actually
since 2017 it was basically done
but a general wireless operations bought
the
trademark and essentially the the
branding of it so they've been using it
guys you're now witnessing what kai
brings the table here this is r
and d right here this is research and
development you're bringing some
some knowledge to the people we're
getting i'm sorry
i was getting too smart right there i'm
just saying this is what he's bringing
to the table here
and then and then gateway computers was
acquired by acer which is another
computer company
uh and if you look at it do you remember
a gateway computer do you remember
gateway remember the name
that was my first laptop do you i
actually remember gateway computer
really
yeah i thought i thought you went into
the store you saw a gateway can be like
bill gates are you kidding me like this
thing could happen was gateway microsoft
what do you mean it wasn't gateway uh
uh no there was the bill gates came out
with a uh computer himself
back in that time really i thought
separate from microsoft
i thought it was uh they never came out
with a computer pc
okay all i'm thinking of in those days
was like dude you're getting a dell
that was the coolest guy in the world i
didn't think about dell i thought about
gateway came out i thought gateway could
have some legs yeah so but so here you
go aol blockbuster radio shack circuit
city comp usa sears hot jobs yahoo
voice stream wireless gateway computers
you were going to say something
uh i know we're going to go deep into
this topic right here but this is very
uh reminiscent of the episode you just
did on how to stay relevant
and very quickly things can change if
you don't compete in the marketplace
so i'm just teeing that one up for you
in the on this segment yeah i mean
you got to realize the hardest part to
do that in is
companies like think about a company
that was relevant in the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s 2000s 2010 2020 think
about companies
it's not that many of them this is like
the whole statistic you read about that
70
of companies in the fortune 500 from
1950
are no longer around 70 because
the number one reason why they're not
around is what high level of competition
new level of innovation
old school gets comfortable casual they
think they're going to be big and
powerful forever somebody who comes and
takes them out if if eight out of these
10 companies are tech companies and
especially considering this is 2000 so
this is right after the
the dot-com bubble and do you think
there's more competition there than
other companies as sears you mean tech
you've been in the town yeah
i'm sure it's not even that there's more
competition
i don't think is that that one industry
lacks competition more than others
although some industries do like if you
think about pepsi versus
coca-cola if you think about pepsi and
coke two guys got the
you know the entire market every time
you come out and you have some kind of
momentum they buy you out here's a
billion here's a billion here's a
billion
get out they buy them out right okay so
duopoly but i think what
the difference is between technology and
all the other industries
technology changes faster so if anything
changes faster
you can go from one moment being a hero
to next moment you're relevant thank you
and no one even knows who you are so
that's the difference between technology
and the rest of the guys
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]